[Music]
here are
uh from comptia.org okay these are signs
that your job is making you sick i'm
going to run through these quickly john
and then and then you and i are going to
break this down what is leadership doing
that are creating these physical
symptoms
and then what does a person do
to try to treat themselves in the
process of deciding do i leave this
environment so here we go one is
insomnia you can't sleep a lot of this
is due to work stress can't get your
mind off of work
and you lay down at night physically and
mentally and emotionally exhausted and
still can't go to sleep uh another one
is you sleep too much
right so you're sleeping too much to
cope with all of the uh elevated
adrenaline and cortisol levels uh three
you're losing weight
you can't even think about eating
because you're so focused on the
fight-or-flight mode from the work four
you're gaining weight
as the adrenaline and cortisol levels
increase due to challenging work
environment it's not uncommon to put on
weight so i know that i'm an emotional
eater so if i had somebody john come at
me
and get all over me and a boss treat me
like you know just like i'm a piece of
junk i'm hitting the chips and salsa oh
yeah i'm just telling you yeah so so i i
just want people to go hey there's no
shame in your game number four that
would be me and when my boss calls me in
and says i just need you to know
you are doing incredible work i go
celebrate with chips and salsa that too
i am an emotional leader i'll have john
diagnose me during the break no i'm the
worst right number five you feel tired
and unmotivated obviously uh fatigue
here high stress too long it's gonna zap
you number six you get colds more often
john you're the first one to kind of
tell me about this i didn't realize how
much stress affects our immune system
yeah it's unbelievable number seven
takes you longer to recover from minor
illnesses because of again
all the factors we've been walking
through number eight you exercise less
off less often you have no motivation
nine you're withdrawing socially
because that unhappiness at work bleeds
into your personal life
and then 10 your doctor starts to
express concern blood pressure
cholesterol levels all
physical effects as a result of a toxic
environment or a horrible boss and i
want to point out a couple things real
quick one
we often look at what our neighbor in
our workplace is going through you think
i'm not going through that
this is important to point out because
stress affects different people
differently because of their life
experiences because of their genetics
because of trauma or not
this stuff ping-pong's around so it's
really important to know your body and i
also think it's important to note this
isn't all causal right this isn't
this causes that this that causes that
usually what happens is you find
yourself so stressed out like we got
here on the back you stop taking care of
your diet yeah quit working out you quit
hanging out with other people you spend
more time scrolling less time sleep and
then all of a sudden these things start
stacking up on it i agree and i think
what you just said is is absolutely
important for people to hear we compound
the problem
let's i just wanted to briefly touch on
a couple leadership things but i want
you to tell the audience okay what do
you do
like how do you self-care in a situation
where you can't leave right away right
cause we let's stress this
we never tell anybody on the king
coleman show or the ramsay show hey
if you're in a tough environment
just walk out today yeah no no no no no
if you financially can then we say yes
but unless unless you've got the
financial wherewithal and freedom to do
so you're gonna have to come up with a
plan and john i want you to talk about
what they can do for self-care but let
me just identify because i want people
to understand that this isn't okay
and so when you've got a leader
who is basically taking their burden and
dumping it on you
and they're going you got to do more
because i can't do anything about it
they're not shouldering the load with
you they're not going this is for a
season this is only going to be here or
they're not rewarding you as a part of
this you are feeling like you are
nothing more than just a person who does
whatever they want whenever they need it
there's no value and that starts to wear
on people that's right that's what's
driving this is people feeling like a
commodity not a person well and and they
get as our friend jacob says they get no
ownership that's it yet all the
responsibility yeah right you don't get
to decide what's going nobody asks your
opinion they tell you what you're going
to do and how you're going to do it when
you're going to do it
and then that's a recipe for dude
i'm going to go have some sort of
autonomy and and be able to speak into
my own life what can the audience do if
they're in this situation to at least
stem the tide of these negative physical
things i think the the most important
thing they can do is to acknowledge this
is happening yeah most of us don't have
it took me years to figure out and draw
begin to connect the dots in my life
that this work environment that i have
to be honest to look in the mirror not
always
but often i was allowing or i was taking
on too much because i wanted to get an
extra certificate or an extra gold star
i was
carrying things about my business and my
industry that nobody asked me to carry
right that's not everybody right that's
me
um you have to call it out and say this
is killing me
this is melting my marriage or i'm not
being the parent i could be because of
this you got to start there with owning
being honest and then
it sounds so uh trite but all you can do
in these situations is control two
things on planet earth you your your
thoughts and your actions yes that's it
that's it don't be afraid to ask for
help
for help ask people to help you with
your thoughts ask for people to help you
with a workout plan ask people to help
you with sleep go see a doctor and then
start asking people to walk it walk
alongside you as they help you find a
new place